Voy a contarles una historia.
Es una historia india sobre una mujer india y su viaje.
Déjenme empezar por mis padres.
Soy producto de una madre
y un padre con visión de futuro.
Hace muchos años, cuando nací en los 50,
los 50 y 60
no eran años para niñas en India.
Eran años para varones.
Para varones que se sumarían a los negocios
y heredarían los negocios de los padres.
Y las niñas se engalanarían para casarse.
Mi familia, en mi ciudad,
y casi en el país, fue única.
Éramos cuatro, no una,
y por suerte no había niños.
Éramos cuatro niñas y ningún niño.
Mis padres pertenecían
a una familia terrateniente.
Mi padre desafió a su propio abuelo
casi hasta el punto de ser desheredado,
porque decidió educarnos
a las cuatro.
Nos mandó a una de las mejores escuelas de la ciudad
y nos dio la mejor educación.
Como he dicho, cuando nacemos no elegimos a nuestros padres.
y cuando vamos al colegio, tampoco lo elegimos.
Los chicos no eligen un colegio,
sólo van al que sus padres eligen por ellos.
Así que esta fue la formación que recibí.
Así fui criada y de igual modo, mis otras tres hermanas.
Y mi padre solía decir entonces:
"Voy a repartir a mis cuatro hijas en cuatro esquinas del planeta".
No sé si realmente pretendía eso, pero así sucedió.
Soy la única que se ha quedado en India.
Una está en Gran Bretaña, otra en EE.UU.
y la otra en Canadá.
Las cuatro estamos en cuatro esquinas del planeta.
Y como he dicho son mis modelos a imitar.
Seguí dos cosas que mi padre y mi madre me decían.
Una, que la vida es una pendiente;
o subes,
o bajas.
Y la segunda, la que siempre he conservado,
la que se convirtió en mi filosofía de vida,
la que ha marcado la diferencia,
es que cien cosas te pasan en la vida, buenas o malas.
De esas 100, 90 son creación propia.
Son buenas. Son tu creación. Disfrútalas.
Si son malas, son tu creación. Aprende de ellas.
10 son producto de la naturaleza y no se puede hacer nada.
Como la muerte de un familiar,
o un ciclón, o un huracán, o un terremoto.
No puedes hacer nada al respecto.
Sólo tienes que responder a la situación.
Pero esa respuesta sale de esos 90 puntos.
Dado que soy producto de esta filosofía
del 90/10,
y que la vida es una pendiente,
esa es la forma en la que crecí,
valorando lo que tengo.
Soy producto de las oportunidades,
oportunidades poco comunes en los años 50 y 60,
que las niñas no recibían.
Y yo era consciente del hecho de que lo que mis padres me estaban dando
era algo único.
Porque mis mejores amigas de la escuela estaban siendo ataviadas
para casarse con mucha dote,
y ahí estaba yo con una raqueta de tenis yendo a la escuela,
y haciendo todo tipo de actividades extraescolares.
Pensé que debía contarles esto,
porque como dije, estos son los antecedentes.
Lo que viene a continuación es esto:
Ingresé en el Servicio de Policía de la India como una mujer dura,
una mujer con energía inagotable
porque solía correr por mis campeonatos de tenis, etc.
Pero ingresé en el Servicio de Policía de la India.
Y entonces apareció un nuevo modelo de policía.
Para mí la policía significaba poder para corregir,
poder para prevenir y para detectar.
Esto es una definición totalmente nueva para la policía india:
el poder para prevenir.
Porque por lo general siempre se había dicho "poder para detectar" y eso era todo,
o "poder para castigar".
Pero yo decidí que no, que es un poder para prevenir
porque eso es lo que aprendí de niña:
¿cómo prevenir el 10 y que nunca sea más de 10?
Así es como ingresé en el servicio
y se diferenció del modelo de los hombres.
No quise diferenciarlo del de los hombres, pero fue diferente,
porque mi manera de ser era diferente.
Y redefiní los conceptos policiales en India.
Los voy a llevar a dar dos viajes:
uno policial y otro carcelario.
Si miran el título dice:
"Detenido el coche del primer ministro".
Era la primera vez que un primer ministro de India
recibía una multa de estacionamiento.
(Risas)
Era la primera vez en India
y puedo asegurarles que fue la última vez que se oyó de eso.
Nunca volvió a suceder en India,
porque fue de una vez y para siempre.
Establecí la regla porque yo era permeable,
compasiva, muy sensible a la justicia,
muy a favor de la justicia.
Esa es la razón por la que, como mujer, ingresé en la policía india.
Tenía otras opciones, pero no las elegí.
Así que voy a continuar.
Se trata de una policía dura, de una policía igualitaria.
Ahora se sabía que aquí había una mujer que no iba a escuchar.
Así que me enviaron a todos los destinos indiscriminadamente;
destinos a los que otros dirían que no.
Hice trabajo penitenciario como oficial de policía.
Normalmente, los policías no quieren ir a las cárceles.
Me enviaron a la cárcel para encerrarme,
pensando que ahora no habría coches
ni gente importante a quien multar.
Encerrémosla.
Así que recibí un trabajo penitenciario.
Era un trabajo penitenciario en una guarida de malvivientes.
Evidentemente lo era.
Eran 10.000 personas,
de las cuales 400 eran mujeres, de 10.000,
y unos 9.600
eran hombres.
Terroristas, violadores,
ladrones, mafiosos...
A algunos los había encarcelado yo
como oficial de policía en la calle.
Y entonces, ¿cómo lidié con ellos?
El primer día cuando entré
yo no sabía cómo mirarlos.
Les dije: "¿Rezan?" Cuando miré al grupo, les pregunté: "¿Rezan ustedes?"
Me veían una mujer joven, baja, vestida con un traje color canela.
Les pregunté: "¿Rezan?"
Y ellos no contestaron nada.
Yo les decía "¿Rezan? ¿Quieren rezar?"
Contestaron: "Sí". Y yo: "Muy bien, recemos".
Recé por ellos y las cosas empezaron a cambiar.
Esta es una diapositiva de la educación dentro de la prisión.
Amigos, esto nunca había sucedido:
todo el mundo estudiando en la prisión.
Empecé esto con el apoyo de la comunidad.
El gobierno no tenía presupuesto.
Fue uno de los mejores voluntariados y más grandes
de cualquier prisión del mundo.
Esto comenzó en la prisión de Delhi.
Pueden ver un ejemplo
de un prisionero dando una clase.
Hay cientos de clases.
De 9 a 11 todos los prisioneros asistían al programa educativo
en la misma guarida en la que pensaron
que me pondrían tras las rejas y todo se olvidaría.
Convertimos esto en un ashram.
De prisión a ashram gracias a la educación.
Creo que es el cambio más grande.
Fue el comienzo de un cambio.
Los maestros eran prisioneros. Los maestros eran voluntarios.
Nos donaron los libros.
Nos donaron la papelería.
Todo nos lo donaron,
porque no había presupuesto educativo para la prisión.
Ahora, si yo no lo hubiese hecho,
eso habría sido un infierno.
Ese es el segundo punto destacado.
Quiero mostrarles algunos momentos de mi viaje,
que probablemente nunca verán en cualquier otra parte del mundo.
Primero, números que nunca van a ver.
Segundo, este concepto.
Este fue un programa de meditación dentro de la prisión
de más de mil reclusos:
1.000 reclusos sentados meditando.
Este fue uno de los pasos más valientes
que di como directora de la prisión.
Y esto es lo que permitió la transformación.
Si quieren saber más acerca de esto
vayan a ver la película "Doing Time, Doing Vipassana".
Van a ver eso y les va a encantar.
Y escríbanme a kiranbedi.com,
que yo les responderé.
Déjenme enseñarle la próxima diapositiva.
Empleé el mismo concepto de meditación.
¿Por qué llevé la meditación a la prisión india?
Porque el crimen es producto de una mente distorsionada.
Hay una distorsión mental que deber tratarse,
no con sermones, ni con cuentos,
ni con lecturas, sino abordando la mente.
Llevé el mismo concepto a la policía
porque la policía, de igual manera, era prisionera de su mente.
Sentían como si hubiese un "nosotros" y un "ellos"
y que las personas no cooperan.
Esto funcionó.
Esta es una caja de comentarios, llamada caja de pedidos.
Este es un concepto que introduje
para escuchar los reclamos, las quejas.
Fue una caja mágica.
Es una caja con sensibilidad.
Así es como dibujó un prisionero qué sentían en la prisión.
Si ven a alguien de azul
-sí, este tipo-
era un recluso, y era maestro.
Y ya ven, todo el mundo está ocupado, no hay tiempo que perder.
Déjenme concluir.
Actualmente, estoy en los movimientos,
los movimientos educativos
de niños que no tienen atención suficiente;
son miles... en India todo es de a miles.
El segundo, es el movimiento anticorrupción de India.
Es un gran procedimiento...
nosotros, como pequeño grupo de activistas,
hemos elaborado un proyecto de ley a favor de un defensor del pueblo de India.
Amigos, van a escuchar mucho al respecto.
Ese el movimiento que estoy impulsando actualmente
y ese es el movimiento y la ambición de mi vida.
Muchas gracias.
(Aplausos)
Gracias. Muchas gracias. Gracias.
Gracias. Gracias. Gracias.